ustedes saben que si tienen una carga
positiva que se encuentra en el espacio
va a crear un campo eléctrico y este
campo eléctrico va a radiar hacia afuera
una onda de la carga positiva y quizás
sepan que si tienen una corriente a
través de un alambre esta corriente va a
crear un campo magnético y este campo
magnético se va a envolver alrededor del
alambre y se va a ver más o menos así
pero las personas comenzaron a darse
cuenta de que hay otra manera de crear
un campo magnético además de tener una
corriente fluyendo y que también hay
otra forma de tener un campo eléctrico
además de tener cargas en el espacio
resulta que si tenemos un campo
eléctrico cambiante
en alguna región del espacio incluso si
esta región no tiene ninguna corriente
en ella por el hecho de que hay un
cambio en el campo eléctrico esto va a
inducir oa crear un campo magnético
aquí hay una manera de crear un campo
magnético del que no se necesita
corriente solo requiere un cambio en el
campo eléctrico de esa región y las
personas también comenzaron a darse
cuenta
ya que si tenemos un campo magnético
cambiante esto va a crear un campo
eléctrico y un físico escocés muy
inteligente llamado james clerk maxwell
se dio cuenta de que si esto es cierto
que un campo eléctrico cambiante puede
crear un campo magnético y a su vez que
un campo magnético cambiante puede crear
un campo eléctrico el que a su vez puede
crear un campo magnético y así
sucesivamente pues podremos crear pues
podemos crear una reacción en cadena que
puede propagarse como una onda tendremos
una onda de campos magnéticos y
eléctricos que puede viajar hacia afuera
y tener una existencia independiente de
la corriente o carga que los originó
como creamos un cambio en el campo
eléctrico
tomamos esta carga y la vamos moviendo
de arriba a abajo
esto parece un antes tendremos están
tener que va a estar cambiando este
campo eléctrico y esto va a crear un
campo magnético que se va a propagar
hacia afuera y de forma similar si
tenemos una corriente como podemos crear
un campo magnético cambiante puedes
cambiando el sentido de la corriente una
y otra vez esto va a crear un campo
magnético cambiante que va a crear un
campo eléctrico y se puede propagar
hacia afuera y ahora esta onda va a
tener su existencia independiente y va a
seguir moviéndose hacia adelante a
cierta velocidad y a esto le llamamos
ondas electromagnéticas electro porque
tiene campos eléctricos magnética porque
tiene campos magnéticos y onda porque se
propaga hacia afuera
siguiendo la ecuación de las ondas de
manera similar a las otras ondas que ya
hemos visto pero hay una diferencia
estas ondas no necesitan un medio para
propagarse pueden viajar por el vacío no
se necesitan partículas de algo aquí
para que esta onda se pueda mover se
pueden propagar en el vacío lo que es
bastante extraño ya que aquí lo único
que se está moviendo o que está
oscilando es el valor de los campos
eléctricos y magnéticos como dibujo de
onda electromagnética este dibujo está
muy feo una onda electromagnética luce
más o menos así las líneas amarillas
representan al campo magnético
y su dirección es hacia arriba y hacia
abajo apunta hacia arriba y hacia abajo
no es que salgan hacia arriba o salgan
hacia abajo lo dibujo de esta manera
pero no es exactamente así como se
comportan lo que trata de decir es que
este punto de aquí no significa que
tenga un campo magnético que vaya así
hacia afuera simplemente tiene su
dirección así y lo dibujo con un vector
más grande para indicar que en este
punto de aquí sobre este eje y este eje
podría ser digamos que la dirección x
por lo que en esta posición en el
espacio hay un campo magnético
relativamente más grande que apunta
hacia arriba y estas líneas rojas
representan el campo eléctrico esta
línea roja de aquí representa
un campo eléctrico relativamente más
grande y el campo eléctrico está en
ángulo recto con el campo magnético
estas son perpendiculares y es así como
ocurre este proceso creará un campo
eléctrico y campo magnético
perpendiculares entre sí el campo
eléctrico apunta hacia afuera del
monitor creo que así es más fácil de que
lo visualicen estas líneas de aquí
apuntan hacia afuera del monitor y esas
líneas de aquí apuntan hacia adentro del
monitor esto ocurre en tres dimensiones
el campo eléctrico oscila hacia afuera y
hacia adentro del monitor el campo
magnético oscila hacia arriba y hacia
abajo y toda la onda viaja hacia la
derecha
y sucede que la dirección de todos estos
elementos se encuentran en ángulos
rectos imaginen un diagrama
tridimensional x y z esta será la
dirección de la velocidad de la onda
aunque no tiene que apuntar en esta
dirección pero imaginen que tenemos la
velocidad en una dirección el campo
magnético estará en esta otra dirección
en jeff y el campo eléctrico en otra
dirección perpendicular a las otras dos
en z estas tres son perpendiculares
entre sí la velocidad es perpendicular
al campo magnético y el campo magnético
es perpendicular al campo eléctrico la
velocidad a la que se mueven estas ondas
es la velocidad de la luz
y se es igual a 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
por segundo debido a que la luz es una
onda electromagnética la luz es un
ejemplo particular de las ondas
electromagnéticas pero éste es sólo un
ejemplo estas ondas electromagnéticas
pueden tener cualquier longitud de onda
por ejemplo de aquí a acá eso es la
gráfica de una
ahonda en el espacio esto va a
representar la longitud de la onda y las
ondas pueden tener cualquier longitud de
onda y también pueden tener cualquier
frecuencia la frecuencia es la tasa con
la cual esto cambia en el tiempo tengo
este punto en el espacio donde hay un
campo magnético va a apuntar hacia
arriba hacia abajo hacia arriba hacia
abajo y la tasa con la cual esto está
ocurriendo el número de cambios por
segundo será la frecuencia así que estas
sondas pueden tener cualquier frecuencia
pero hay una región especial esta región
es la del espectro visible esa es la
región de frecuencias y longitudes de
onda que pueden tener las ondas
electromagnéticas el espectro
electromagnético y hay mucho que
aprender con respecto a este espectro
electromagnético ahorita lo
mencionaremos de manera rápida si
nosotros gráfica vamos a lo largo de
esta línea aquí tendremos las
frecuencias más altas o las mayores
frecuencias hacia la derecha que estará
en hertz que es cómo medimos las
frecuencias
debido a esta fórmula la velocidad de la
onda es lambda por efe o la longitud de
la onda por la frecuencia si la
frecuencia aumenta la longitud de onda
tiene que decrementar pse así que hacia
la derecha tendremos menores longitudes
de onda y las longitudes de onda se
miden en metros pero cuando hablamos de
la luz ya que tenemos unas longitudes de
onda tan pequeñas normalmente aquí
hablaremos de nanómetros en dónde estará
el espectro visible puede ser espectro
visible será este pedacito de aquí
esto es el espectro electromagnético
y el espectro visible está aquí esto es
lo que podemos ver entre el rojo y el
violeta y el rojo tiene la frecuencia de
alrededor de 4 por 10 a la 14
hertz y el violeta tendrá 7.5 por 10 a
la 14
hertz más o menos o si queremos hablar
de la longitud de onda el rojo tendrá
750 nanómetros
y el violeta tendrá alrededor de 400
nanómetros
y recordemos que nano se refiere a 10 a
la menos nueve pero bueno recordemos que
esta es una región muy pequeña tendremos
mayores frecuencias al del violeta ya
éstos les llamamos ultravioleta
y sabemos que estas no son buenas para
nosotros no son buenas porque si nos
dirigimos hacia la derecha donde hay
mayores frecuencias resulta que eso
también significa que tenemos una onda
de mayor energía
si hablamos de fotones que forman esta
luz hablando de mecánica cuántica estos
fotones conforme nos vamos hacia la
región de mayor frecuencia van a tener
mayor energía lo que significa que son
más peligrosos ya que como tienen más
energía pueden transferir esta energía
hacia otras partes como a las células
dañando las y es por eso que al menos
para este tipo de luz nosotros nos
ponemos bloqueador solar para
protegernos de los rayos ultravioleta
pero esta no es la frecuencia más alta
podemos tener ondas con mayores
frecuencias tenemos los rayos x los
rayos xy tienen mayor frecuencia y por
lo tanto son más peligrosos por lo cual
los técnicos que sacan las radiografías
se van detrás de un muro que nos protege
de estos rayos ya que de otra manera
está recibiendo tanta cantidad de rayos
x- cada día les haría mucho daño
pero eso tampoco es la frecuencia más
alta tenemos algo llamado rayos gamma y
los rayos gamma tienen una cantidad
increíble de energía lo cual los hace
tremendamente peligrosos estos rayos
vienen del espacio o también de cierto
tipo de reacciones nucleares
y es por eso que muchas veces se
encuentran en los cómics que la razón
por la que surge algún superhéroe es
porque fue atravesado por rayos gamma
nada más porque suene bastante poderoso
aunque en la realidad no transforma a la
gente en superhéroes pero sin duda tiene
mucha energía y hacia abajo tenemos los
infrarrojos
esto está por debajo del rojo esto es el
infrarrojo y por debajo de éste
tenemos las microondas y en la región de
las microondas tenemos muchas cosas
útiles están los celulares las señales
que están en la región de microondas
señales de televisión se envían por el
aire en la región de microondas y por
debajo de esta tenemos las ondas de
radio
aun cuando técnicamente hablando las
regiones de radio de fm se encuentran
más cercanas a la región de las
microondas y aquí tenemos al radio am
las primeras ondas que se usaban cuando
se inventó el radio las frecuencias de
radio por acá son las frecuencias de am
y este es el espectro electromagnético
el rango visible es una pequeña región
de todo este y no podemos ver nada más
fuera de esta región pero sin duda esta
es bastante útil para muchos casos
diferentes y peligrosos así que
necesitamos conocer todo el espectro
electromagnético